but that wasn't the real story the real
story is that antifa and blm showed up
and naturally violence ensued
this is the way that it usually works
usually what happens here is that there
is uh there's
some sort of trump rally some sort of
trump event and then people from blm and
antifa
show up and then confrontation naturally
ensues
some of these confrontations are from
sort of the most aggressive members of
the trump crowd and blm antifa and
sometimes it's just blm and anti for
beating the hell out of innocent people
like people who are not confrontational
in any way uh
here was some of the videos that were
that were happening
you can see that there's a this guy
who's getting in confrontations with
members of antifa and blm he's
confronting a bunch of people
and uh he's uh he's hit in the back of
the head uh and knocked to the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
and they steal a cell phone as well
people kicking him while he's down so
that
all sorts of wonderful things happening
in washington you see this man walking
literally just walking
with his mega hat people jumping at him
uh people assaulting him
him just kind of standing there while
people crowd around him to do violence
to him
i'm not one of them very classy stuff
happening in washington d.c people were
arrested some 20 people arrested
apparently one person was stabbed
in washington dc also uh some trump
folks were eating at a restaurant in
washington dc and they didn't get the
memo you're not allowed to eat at a
restaurant in washington dc unless you
pay the
the tax to blm and so people started
throwing fireworks at people
at the restaurant so that's solid stuff
you can see here people just weren't up
and there they go somebody at blm and
antifa just throwing fireworks at people
inside a restaurant
which is delightful that's the good
stuff happening here
don't worry guys it's trump's crowd
that's violent trump's people are the
violent people that's what we've been
told by the media we've been told that
it's trump's people
who are the violent ones as opposed to
you know blm and antifa showing up so
where was
captain healing in unity seriously where
was captain healing in unity
joe biden has spent the entire campaign
avoiding condemning blm
despite the fact that dozens of blm
quote-unquote protests have broken out
into riot
he spent the entire campaign completely
ignoring the fact that antifa is a
violent group
instead suggesting it's more of like a
philosophy like a generalized philosophy
which is a really
cheap way of getting out of having to
condemn the most radical members of your
base
but radicalism is the theme among
democrats right the real battle right
now
is not happening between the right and
the left the real battle is supposedly
happening inside the democratic party
i've been suggesting that there is no
battle
that a lot of what's happening inside
the democratic party right now is a is a
shadow
battle that basically the only battle is
whether
joe biden and company can keep a lid on
the simmering pot of discontent that is
the democratic base
or whether eventually they're just
hijacked by that base and you can see it
happening
in real time i don't think that joe
biden has the passion
to actually contain that i think there's
a pressure cooker the democratic party
and i think that joe biden and others
have assumed that if you turn up the
temperature on the pressure cooker well
all that's going to do is cook the meat
thoroughly
but eventually what ends up happening is
the pressure cooker blows and i think
that that pressure cooker is not likely
to remain in stasis for very long i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content